des voitures calcinées et des immeubles
détruits ces images diffusées par les
autorités séparatistes proruses de
denièsk montre une soledar déserte et
des soldats russes patrouillants dans
les rues des scènes loin des trains
dedans trois jours après la
revendication par Moscou de la conquête
de la ville à la télévision russe
Vladimir Poutine a affirmé que ses
troupes avaient dans l'est de l'Ukraine
la dynamique est positive et tout se
déroule selon les plans du ministère de
la Défense et de l'état-major j'espère
que nos combattants vont encore nous
ravir plus d'une fois avec leurs
résultats militaires
dont le viseur de l'armée russe barmut
une prise qui lui permettrait de
poursuivre la conquête du non-basse mais
le président ukrainien l'affirme la
lutte pour sollédard n'est pas terminée
la bataille porcelée d'art pour barmut
pour les régions de Donetsk et de
l'ougansk continue sans répit je suis
reconnaissant envers nos combattants
des combattants unis au contraire des
forces russes le groupe paramilitaire
Wagner et le ministère de la Défense
entoura tout revendiqué la prise de
soledar mais selon le Kremlin il n'y a
aucune division
sont le produit de manipulation
des manipulations qui viennent parfois
de nos adversaires et parfois de nos
propres amis
et qui agissent d'une manière telle que
nous n'avons pas besoin d'ennemis en ce
moment
le porte-parole du Kremlin a également
promis de brûler les charges challengeur
2 qui seront prochainement livrés à Kiev
par le Royaume-Uni